we would of course like any encounter
with mental illness to be as brief as
possible
and most importantly to be isolated and
singular
but the reality is that for many of us
the illness will threaten to return for
visits throughout our lives
it will be a condition to which we will
be permanently susceptible
so the challenge isn't to learn to
survive only a one-off crisis it's to
set in place a framework
that can help us to manage our fragility
over the long term
some of the following moves practical
and psychological
suggest themselves acknowledgement
being ready for a return of the illness
will help us to calibrate our
expectations
and render us appropriately patient and
unfrightened
in the face of relapses we felt ill
over many years our whole childhood
might have been the incubating
laboratory
and it will therefore take us an age
until we are impervious
we should expect to recover no more
speedily than someone who has damaged a
limb
and probably a good deal more arduously
given how complicated a mind is next to
a femur
or a tendon mental management
we need to be rigorous with our patterns
of thinking
we cannot afford to let our thoughts
wander into any old section of the mind
there are thoughts that we need to
nurture about
our worth about our right to be about
the importance of keeping going
about self-forgiveness and there are
thoughts we should be ruthless in
chasing out
about how some people are doing so much
better than us
about how inadequate and pitiful we are
about what a disappointment we have
turned out to be
the latter aren't even thoughts they
have no content to speak of
they are really just instruments of
torture and symptoms of a difficult past
a support network a decent
social life isn't for the mentally
fragile a luxury
or piece of entertainment it is a
resource to help us to stay alive
we need people to balance our minds when
we are slipping
we need friends who will be soothing
with our fears
and not accuse us of self-indulgence or
self-pity
for the amount of time our illness has
sequestered
it will help immensely if they have
struggles of their own
and we can therefore meet as equal
fellow ailing humans
as opposed to hierarchically separated
doctors and patients
we'll need ruthlessness in expunging
certain other people from our diaries
people who harbor secret resentments
against us
who are latently hostile to
self-examination
who are scared of their own minds and
project their fears onto us
a few hours with such types can throw a
shadow over a whole day
their unsympathetic voices become lodged
in our minds
and we feed our own ample stores of
self-doubt
we shouldn't hesitate to socially edit
our lives in order to endure
vulnerability the impulse when things
are darkening
is to hide ourselves away and reduce
communication
we are too ashamed to do anything else
we should fight the tendency
and precisely when we cannot bear to
admit what we are going through
we should dare to take someone into our
confidence
silence is the primordial enemy we have
to fight a permanent feeling
that we are too despicable to be looked
after
we have to take a gamble on an always
implausible idea
that we deserve kindness love
love is ultimately what will get us
through not romantic love
but sympathy tolerance and patience
we'll need to watch our tendencies to
turn love down
from an innate sense of unworthiness we
wouldn't have become
ill if it weren't entirely easy for us
to accept the positive attention of
others
we'll have to thank those who are
offering it and make them feel
appreciated in return and most of all
accept that our illness from the outset
was rooted in a deficit of love
and therefore that every encounter with
the emotion
will strengthen our recovery and help to
keep the darkness at bay
pills we would ideally of course prefer
not to keep adding foreign chemicals to
our minds
there are side effects and the eerie
sense of not knowing exactly where our
thoughts end an alien neurochemistry
begins
but the ongoing medicines set up guard
rails around the worst of our mental
whirlpools
we may have to be protected on an
ongoing basis
from forces inside us that would prefer
we didn't exist
a quiet life we should see the glory
and the grandeur that is present in an
apparently modest destiny
we are good enough as we are we don't
need huge sums of money
or to be spoken of well by strangers we
should take pride in our early nights
and undramatic routines these aren't
signs of passivity or tedium
what looks like a normal life on the
outside is a singular achievement given
what we are battling within
humor there is no need for gravity
we can face down the illness by laughing
heartily at its evils
we are mad and cracked but luckily so
are many others with whom we can riley
mock the absurdities of mental life
we shouldn't on top of everything else
accord our illness
too much portentous respect we should be
proud of ourselves for making it this
far
it may have looked at times as if we
never would
there might have been nights when we
sincerely thought of taking our own
lives
somehow we held on we reached out for
help
we dared to tell someone else of our
problems we engaged our minds
we tried to piece together our histories
and to plot a more endurable future
and we started reading about what might
be up with us
we are still here mentally ill no doubt
at times
but more than ever committed to recovery
appreciative of the light
grateful for love and keen to help
anyone else whose plight we can
recognize
we are not fully well but we are on the
mend
and that for now is very much good
enough
one of the trickiest tasks we ever have
to face
is that of working out who we really are
this book is designed to help us create
a psychological portrait of ourselves
with the use of some unusual oblique
entertaining and playful prompts
click the link on screen now to find out
more